have you seen The Lion King [ __ ] yeah  dude  he was like nope I haven't I haven't but  for this bit yeah you know like uh Simba  Simba yeah and and uh the hog what's up  what's are they friends they're friends  okay good I think I feel like that's you  and I who's who am I you're the old hog  and I'm the Young Lion wouldn't it be  more like Timon and Pumbaa  medium Dick Energy right we're homies  Bobby what I love about our thing is  um we're so opposite uh it's good it's a  good Duo I like that it's a good Duo if  I was like a tall six foot two white  dude with like blonde hair I'd  immediately resent you you would resent  me when like another like tall good  looking alpha male walks in a room right  I start sitting a little straighter